fox and friends weekend co-host pete
heggseth he's a firebrand
he wrote the book firebrand florida
congressman matt gates
all right mr firebrand i
read this that vladimir putin
hostile regime russia hostile actor is
calling out the president
and he's calling him out for a reason am
i right or wrong
putin and biden it would not end like
rocky
iv i don't think the american would
prevail
obviously vladimir putin effectively
trolling the president united states
and i want to make sure that we are the
strongest country on the international
stage and it doesn't help
that joe biden in almost every
international negotiation
is conceding to these globalist entities
now when it comes
to the biden tax plan we're all
wondering why is this a time that you'd
want to punish
job creators those who are innovating
those who are bringing
capital investment to our country and
increasing the wages
of our workers it seems counterintuitive
to do this type of violence to our
country
and when it comes to the harris biden
relationship
everyone in washington knows that every
time kamala harris
shakes the hand of joe biden she's
checking his pulse shawn
oh ouch that's painful pete how excited
your take
there are a lot of people that are in
front of joe biden to be president right
now not just
kamala harris which we all know i mean
nancy pelosi chuck schumer who
who is also uh effectively controlled by
comrade cortez who lives rent free
in his head of course you have bernie
sanders who should have been the nominee
twice
and susan rice who was who was part of
the obama administration is now the
domestic policy advisor
all of them are deciding what gets in
front of joe biden
before or after he takes his nap so that
their policy priorities can be moved
forward but here's the sad thing about
the putin thing
uh it might be putin trolling biden but
it's because putin doesn't believe
america under the biden biden leadership
is a fundamentally serious place
they see us obsessed with woke-ism at
war with ourselves
drowning in debt with a with a with the
commander in chief who's totally absent
and they believe the prerogative in the
future is theirs and oh by the way
tonight
xi jinping sent a delegation to alaska
to meet with
uh biden's delegation you want to talk
about a real killer
how about china how about what they want
to do for the future and guess what the
chinese delegation said to
our delegation just now this is very
recent in anchorage they said
the she delegation tells the biden
delegation they don't have the
qualifications to say to china
that they speak from a position of
strength you think xi ji ping
thinks america is in his position of
strength or vladimir putin of course
they don't
it's because joe biden's approach to the
world and our country is fundamentally
unserious
and they know it it's one scary question
and if you compare president trump i
personally believe and i think i'm right
matt case they generally
feared trump they feared that he meant
what he said and he said what he meant
and they push him he would do it
i don't know how they feel about biden
now there's always uncertainty because
there are other people
that clearly will have influence in any
decision moving forward
my question is this this to me
this is now officially dangerous we got
to remember one thing
the world has evil in it the last
century alone what did we learn
communism mao stalin russia
nazism fascism what did we learn 100
million human souls are destroyed
so evil is real the united states is to
lead the free world the cause of freedom
to act as a deterrent and be strong as a
deterrent against such right
i agree i also believe that russia is
not the great threat that
some in the establishment would portray
it pete's right
china is the real threat that faces our
generation and our country
and we will not defeat china in a world
in which we portray weakness
today joe biden portrays that very
weakness
in his stature in his ability to address
problems
in his acuity and when we get down to
the elements of the trump presidency
that we want to maintain
on trade on international engagement on
focusing our foreign policy
against the middle kingdom not the
middle east it's important that
we continue to preserve that america
first doctrine
because i think joe biden wants to take
us back to a world in which we threat
construct
around russia rather than focusing on
the real threat
that will drive whether or not america
continues to lead
another generation of global success
pete last word 30 seconds
sean you don't look strong when you have
razor wire around your own capital
yet the national guardsmen you have
defending it have no ammunition in their
rifles
because the whole thing is a sham and a
show
for nancy pelosi and democrats to try to
portray their political opponents as
insurrectionists when you were at war
with yourself
and and the president united states
doesn't know what day of the week it is
there's no chance the rest of the world
takes you seriously and that's how
dangerous this moment is
with president trump they knew we meant
business with biden
they have no clue which means it's time
to play and the world gets more
dangerous
pete heg says thank you congressman matt
firebrand gates thank
you